hi everyone this is gung from stanford
and i will talk about uh key
characteristics of
the main optimal stable matching in
random matching markets with tears
and this is based on joint work with
italian
mark braverman clay thomas and amin
sabari
we will study the stable marriage
problem which
in the standard analogy describes
matching and men to and women
where each of the agents has a complete
preference order
over all agents on the other side and we
will be concerned about
the stable matchings which is defined as
matchings
where there are no pairs of men and
women
who wants to deviate from their
currently assigned partner to each other
instead
in particular we want to study the main
optimal state of matching
which is given by the algorithm called
men proposing deferred acceptance or
da in short and it is also commonly
referred to as
the gale shapley algorithm in this
algorithm we have men
proposing to women in the order of their
preferences
and women upon receiving proposals will
tentatively
accept the best proposal they have seen
so far
and the process continues until all men
are matched or equivalently until the
last woman
receives and has accepts the last
proposal from the last man
we have seen a bunch of literature
studying the
behaviors of the stable matches in
markets where the agent's preferences
are homogeneous or
the preferences are uniformly random and
this can be seen in various
literatures from even many decades ago
until recently on
balanced and unbalanced markets however
we generally know very little about
markets where the preferences are
non-uniform
that means the distribution of
preferences are not
uniformly random so this work
will be devoted to studying the
difference in quality
across agents on both sides and in
particular we want to tackle the
following two
problems first we want to deduce
the expected rent for each agent in the
market so the rank is defined as
the index of one's partner in this
individual's preference list
and we want to mention that lower means
better here for ranks
because if you have rank 1 it means
you're matched to your favorite
partner and the second problem
is the distribution of match types which
means
what fraction of the matches are between
men and women
of certain types or certain tiers which
we will formalize in the next slide
we consider this model for tiered
matching markets
where we have ant men and women shown
here and
each side will be divided into a fixed
number of tiers
and the tiers are a fractional size
delta
for men and excellence for women and
for each tier of men or women we have
positive score where we consider as
weight
associated with each of the agents to
mark their quality
and the higher the better the
preferences for each agent will be
generated
independently by sampling without
replacement
from all agents on the other side
and the sampling probability is
proportional to
the individual's public scores on the
other side
so for example each man will sample
women without replacement and
the probability is alpha i which is the
score of each woman
over n epsilon dot alpha as vector
dot products which is just the sum of
all scores for women
and the key assumption here is that all
preferences are iip
we want to give you a quick overview of
our core results
first uh we showed that the rank of
agent
on each side is essentially inversely
proportional to
his or her score and second the
distribution of match types
which is the fraction of matches between
men and women of different tiers
is essentially uniform and both results
hold
when the market is sufficiently large
now to zoom in on our first result about
average rep
and again just to remind you here lower
means better
if we adopt a notation of of a mean
standing for the minimum among all of us
for women
and beta inverse as a vector is the
component-wise inverse of the beta
vector
we have the expected rank for tier j
men and ti women given by
these two expressions marked as 1 and 2.
so there are quite a few terms but we
want to give you some
core insight out of them you will first
notice that asymptotically these are
really the same as what we have for the
uniform market
namely it is non-end for men's average
rank and
end over long end for women's rent and
apparently
men who are proposing here are having
a very large advantage over women who
receive proposals
and second to individual level
a man or woman's rent at expected rank
is essentially inversely proportional to
his or her score
as you can see in the dependency on
alpha i and beta j in the denominator
and finally we comment down that tiers
on one side
are in fact affected the same amount by
the tier structure on the other side
as you can see that the highlighted
terms have no dependency on ing
and our second piece of result is about
the distribution of batch type
and this might be a bit surprising at
the first look as we showed that
in expectation the fraction of matches
between two j men and t
i women is just delta j times epsilon i
and these are the two fractional sizes
of the two tiers
in their corresponding size and in other
words this just means that
the distribution of mesh type is
approximately uniform
as these fractions do not depend on
the quality or scores among each tier
this might be some kind of surprising
given that
our previous result shows that higher
tier men actually
are expected to be better off
proportionally than lower tier men
but here we are essentially observing
that in a macroscopic view
higher tier men in fact don't really
have an advantage in getting matched
to higher tiered women and this also
indicates that
our model with gaps in quality
of a finite amount really doesn't give
a lot of predictive power on the mesh
type
for each individual
and from the rest of the talk we'll
spend some time going over some quick
ideas and observations for our proof and
we'll finally
talk about some extensions so
first the first step in the curve is to
consider the total number of proposals
and in fact
notice that in our model we have tiers
on both sides and
to simplify our proof we will actually
split our
problem into two pieces and by
considering the subcases of having only
tears in the women's side
and then tears only in the men's side
and it turns out that these two
sub cases compose very well
so for now we consider the simplified
case where
men are uniform and women are divided
into tears
our results mentioned earlier in fact
simplified into this
which is average ranks for men and women
of different tiers
the intuition here for this sub case
is that essentially men are competing to
avoid in some sense to get matched to
lower tier women and it's actually easy
to see that
women of better scores or higher quality
attracts more proposals from men
proportionally than their lower score
counterparts
also a side common is that we'll notice
that
women's rents are not dependent on the
tier
sizes absolutes for each woman
her expected rent only depends on her
score
and actually the score of the lowest
tier
women we start by studying the total
number of proposals
during the deferred acceptance process
and
imagine in the uniform market this is
actually pretty well studied and this is
just very similar to a coupon collector
problem
where ti marks the time or the number of
proposals needed
for the i distinct woman to receive a
proposal
and we only need to take the sum of ti
for i uh from one to n where n is the
number of
all women and it's easy to
see that uh this is essentially n
times log n of course there's a slight
nuance because
in different acceptance man will not
propose to the same woman again but
coupon collector you may collect
the same coupon multiple times but it's
actually very easy to show that the
effect
the difference here is very small and
insignificant
to handle the tiered market we start by
noticing that
the bottom tier as we said earlier in
fact is the least popular and received
least proposal
so it is expected that the bottom tier
will receive the final proposal that
terminates the different acceptance
process
and using the same coupon collector
argument we can
show that the number of proposals to the
bottom tier
will be roughly this absolute mean times
n
and then times log of absolute mean
times m
where absolute min marks the size of the
worst tier
and also we know that in expectation we
should have
these so many fraction of proposals
among all proposals that go
to the bottom tier so that indicates
that the
total number of proposals must be n
times log log n
uh up to a constant factor that depends
on the tier structure of the women
and based on this is it is very easy to
deduce the average rank of
men which is just this divided by n and
also
the average number of proposals received
by each
one because we know they distribute
proportionally to a score
and the second case is where we have men
in tears and
women are uniform and this helps us to
study
the distribution of proposals from
different tiers of men
and our earlier results simplified into
these expressions for men and women
and in fact we want to emphasize that um
what we really need to show is just
that rank for men is um proportional to
one over beta their scores
uh because the grade out factor
in the denominator is really just the
normalizing constant to make the average
rank of math
to be um log n as we showed earlier
and our main tool for studying this
proof
is that it is well known in the
70s that the deferred acceptance process
is independent of the order of proposals
so if you want to study the rank of a
man
m star we may just hold him and let all
other men propose and find a match
before
m star does and then lets m star
proposed and possibly kicking off some
other men
who will eventually make proposals to
the last um
last woman and the second tool
is the principle of deferred decisions
which is a
crucial part in our proof so in this
case we consider
this gamma sub w to be the sum of scores
from all the proposers to a woman w
and at this step if m star proposes to w
the proposal will be accepted with a
probability a better start over
with a star plus the sum of all previous
scores
um as you can see this is basically w
making her
decision of whether to accept or reject
on the fly and with those tools we now
have the result relying on these
following dilemmas
first we claim that with high
probability
no man will make too many proposals here
for example too many
can be log square of n which is
essentially little o of
n that's what we care about and
second we only say that most women have
upon the very end of day's process
received a lot of proposals and this is
not surprising because we know the
proposals go to women
as iid random variables and that should
be very good
bound on concentration
so with this dilemma let's consider a
man m
with a score for example one proposing
last
and before he is about to propose
let's consider the process already done
and define little p
to be the probability that m samples
a woman out of the entire population
and propose and get accepted
and as we have mentioned earlier this is
just the expectation of 1 over
1 plus gamma w where w is drawn
from the sampling distribution so
imagine m were to propose with
replacement
and that means he will sample a woman
and propose maybe rejecting by simple
uh independently a second woman
if this were the case then the number of
proposals until
he got the first acceptance is exactly
geometric
random variable of probability p
however we know there's some deviation
because he will not be
proposing with replacement but we know
that he will not make too many proposals
in fact no one will have too many
proposals
so the difference here is actually
insignificant
and although not exactly this number of
proposals
is roughly geometric of p
also the second lemma tells us that uh
when the woman accepts m
she should be very happy about m and m
should be
very likely to stay at his first
acceptance
in fact the likelihood is the concept
order
also if the market is large then we have
the scammer w the sum of squares also
being large
we observe the following approximation
which tells us that
if we define p prime similar to p to be
the probability of acceptance
except for a man with square beta
then p prime is roughly just beta times
p
so of course our previous discussion
depending on the setup
mu before and actually makes his
proposals
so now what we need to show is that
for all setups this is in fact true
that the number of proposals needed for
m
is roughly the geometric of a parameter
that is proportional to
this men's score beta and this will lead
us to our final
result about mass number of proposal
where
essentially it says the number of
proposals made by each man
is proportional to one over beta
finally as the last step we will combine
the results in the previous two
and we consider markets with tiers on
both sides
so the key takeaway here is that we have
the expected number of proposals from
all men
in for example tier j to a woman w in
tier i
given by this expression i noticed that
the blue terms
highlighted the dependency on the men's
tier j
in other words we observe that this
number
is proportional to the woman's score and
inversely proportional to the men's
score of that tier
and this result allows us to recover our
original
form of the expected ranks for
women in each tier and men in each tier
finally we want to devote a minute or
two
to the distribution of match time a
result that we
found is a pretty interesting
since we know the number of proposals
from each tier of men to
women in each tier we can now ask what
is the probability that
a woman has her favorite proposal from
uh men in tier j notice that
uh each of these proposals can be the
favorite
with probability proportional to beta j
and the number of such proposals is
inversely proportional to
beta j and this combined means that a
woman w
will favor a man in tier j as her
favorite with probability independent of
beta j
and only depending on in fact the tier
size delta g
and therefore we got the result about
the uniform
match type distribution which says in
expectation the fraction of matches
between different tiers of men and women
is just the
product of the corresponding fractional
tier sizes
and again we want to emphasize that the
intuition behind this result is that
lower tier men or men of worse quality
will make more proposals in order to get
accepted
and on the other hand each of the
proposal is also
less likely to be the favorite
so these two effects exactly counteract
each other
and specifically for example a top tier
man
is less likely to propose to
a bottom tier woman but if he does so
his proposal is more likely to win and
on the other hand on the other hand
we will have a huge amount of bottom two
men proposing to talk to women
and those women are likely to take maybe
at least one of those men this result
indicates that our model
of constant disparity tears of quality
in fact does not enforce much april
structure
on the resulted match type
and finally we will talk about some
possible extensions and future work
first we would like to generalize our
model to include individualized scores
as opposed to scores of a limited or
finite number of tiers in fact as long
as we have independence
our tools should still apply but we do
need to develop
new methods to handle correlated scores
if
if we desire the second interesting
direction
is to study the imbalanced markets
where for example there are fewer men
than women
because as we have seen such market x
has been very different characteristics
as
a balanced market and also we have
observed that
in such market the rank wouldn't be
exactly inversely proportional to the
score
and also that we have seen that the mesh
type will not be
strictly uniform again in in balanced
markets
and finally we want to ask how our model
can contribute to the study of mechanism
design
for example if you consider the actual
problem of matching
doctors to hospitals through interviews
there is actually additional costs
associated with
each application and this is not
captured in our
current model so far further we may also
study
more permissive models where for example
stability
can have some more general and relaxed
definition
that is different than the current
standard definition of
strict stability